l'été approche et une vingtaine
d'organisations de professionnels de la
santé sonne alarme
l'été dernier on le vit de façon
drastique les gens sont venus aux
urgences la vague de chaleur eu des
impacts sound system les changements
climatiques et les canicules ou qui les
accompagnent entraîne la mort de gens
vulnérables
la coalition avance même le chiffre de
vingt mille décès d'ici 50 ans c'est des
maladies qu'on voyait pas avoir cédé ce
qu'on appelle des défaillances multi
systémique les gens décèdent pas mais
sur un an tombant d'un sens rénale en
instance respiratoires aux soins
intenses et pendant des jours des
semaines des mois et finissent par
mourir
depuis huit ans la maladie de lyme gagne
aussi du terrain
plus de 340 été dénombrés au québec en
2018 contre 32 en 2011
l'éthique qui se développe dans de
nouveaux territoires et donc leurs
régions où ils peuvent vivre grandir et
se multiplier se développe s'étendre
pour ces professionnels de la santé
le québec doit réduire de façon
draconienne sa dépendance aux énergies
fossiles
il prône le transport collectif et
l'arrêt de tout projet d'exploration et
d'exploitation d'hydrocarbures
on aurait vu toute la littérature sur la
fracturation hydraulique l'été dernier
et il ya des problèmes sérieux il ya des
problèmes de retards de croissance chez
les bébés des études ont monté des
problèmes de malformations debroux
neurologiques ou niveau cérébral de plus
de cancers chez les enfants
quant à la multiplication des vagues de
chaleur estivales
la ministre de la santé du déjà se
préparer on a fait le relevé dans
l'ensemble de nos centres d'hébergements
et you pour je pense 92% des centres
d'hébergement et notamment les ondes du
québec où il fait plus chaud là ya des
endroits climatisés
québec souhaite que les personnes âgées
puissent avoir accès à une pièce
climatisée dans l'ensemble des ch et
celle des de la province ici marie-eve
cousineau radio canada montréal